I love series of sequences series and
sequences is a fantastic topic there's a
lot of fun to it and it's very like I
said different from what you've been
doing recently which is kind of um it
sort of turned a little bit into death
by algebra you trying to see something
on a diagram it's not connecting this is
going to get into calculus territory
before too long you remember I said to
you that's actually the main reason why
we're learning at this term ahead of the
topics later in the term and one of the
key pieces to get us there is this idea
we're moving from the idea of a sequence
a bunch of things in order to a series
so a partial sum is what happens when
you add up the terms in a sequence so
it's another name for a series that's a
finite well comes a series that aren't
finite series that are infinite a little
bit later on but one step at a time so
in order to get there and build this
understanding let's recall what we've
got so far okay so we know what a set is
we know the sequences we know what a
series is there's very big-ticket ideas
we call sequences and series one big
word that starts with pay that sort of
overarching remember what the word was
we've got a progression right because
you progress from one term to the next
there's a there are earlier terms there
are later terms you only have that when
you have an idea of order okay excuse me
now under progressions we looked at two
particular kinds of progressions and
they had some very handy acronyms
remember what they were we talked about
a piece or arithmetic progressions and
what we developed was a little formula
for the nth term in an arithmetic
progression we started we always start
with the first term which we called a
and then because an arithmetic
progression is about adding things right
it's like you've got a common common
difference if you add up some number of
those to get to be in the term we said
well the number of common differences
you add up is always 1 less than the
term you're on ok because the first term
doesn't have any of them the second term
is 1/3
has to so this is what we developed okay
we then said alright if you advance from
term to term not by addition but by
multiplication we don't call that an AP
we call it a a GP a geometric
progression and in just the same way we
fit we came up with a formula for the
nth term of a GP right we said you again
start with the first term but there's
not a comma difference there's a common
ratio so we had an R and it's the same
deal
you're always lagging one behind so
that's where that n minus one comes from
okay so this is where we are at what we
want to go to from here is what happens
when you don't have the nth term but the
sum of the first n terms so I'm going to
find some new notation for us right
let's define if this is of the nth term
then I'm going to define s of M as the
sum of the first n terms the way that I
would write that algebraically is you
start from term one yeah add turn to you
add two three
there's my pattern you see I needed
three terms and you keep on adding until
you get to the nth term which is two
events okay so here is my my nd here
right so in words I said this the first
time what this means is the sum of the
first n terms okay so what we say we're
mathematicians say partial sum this is
what they're referring to right you take
part of a series for example if we were
talking about this series of the
sequence rather of odd numbers 1 3 5 7 9
11 etc okay I could say what is the sum
of the first 5 terms 1 plus 3 plus 1
plus 3 plus 5 plus 7 plus 9 okay it's a
partial sum it's not every odd number
that ever exists it's just part of that
sequence okay hence the name now what
we're going to do is just like we did
for these guys we developed these
formulas right we fought them through we
did some algebra we're going to develop
the formulas for these guys
for APS and GPS okay and it involves
some interesting tricks so let's start
with ApS first
there's a a famous German mathematician
his name was Gauss and he was a really
really smart guy and the the story goes
that as like a a really young primary
school-aged kid he was just so smart he
would always cause problems for the
teacher because he was always bored
because he was so clever and so the
teacher thought I know what I'm gonna do
I've got a great idea
I'm just gonna give this boy a task he
likes nobody likes Matz
there's just gonna keep him busy for a
while so the teacher said okay little
mustard gas here's what I want you to do
I want you to didn't obviously use this
language but I want you to add up a
particular arithmetic progression here's
the arithmetic progression he was given
take every number every counting number
1 2 3 etc and add them all all way all
the way up to 100 okay add up 100
numbers that'll keep you busy ok and gas
off you go into the corner and much to
the teachers dismay or so the story goes
he came back about 15 seconds later and
said the answer is and provided the sum
now how did he do it so fast what was he
thinking you know par from just being a
smart guy adding up 100 numbers takes a
long time so what kinds of patterns can
we take advantage of mass is always
about patterns that will help us to work
out what this sum is really really
quickly now what I want us to do is I've
go ahead write that partial sum the
first 100 counting numbers what I'm
going to do is I'm actually going to
provide a little bit of extra
information here that doesn't look like
it's necessary but will help us ok in
order to know what this partial sum is
you've got to know the pattern so I
needed the first three terms you've got
to know where you end right so this is
the sum of the first 100 terms that's
enough information to know everything
about this series about this partial sum
but I'm gonna add in a little extra
information at the
of the series to mirror what's happening
at the start so if I start with 1 plus 2
Plus 3 and add up some number of numbers
I know I ended 100 but what happens just
before 100 and the answer is will 99
happens just for 498 happens just before
that I'm going to include those guys now
Gauss's insight really really clever
gases insight was that if you think
about this from the left hand side you
go from left to right by adding 1 right
you're progressing from left to right
you're always increasing but you can
just as easily look at this object from
the other way
do you notice I could have written this
particular partial sum as starting from
a hundred and then counting down right
so you've got this kind of symmetry here
in this partial sum as a consequence you
could think about this a couple of ways
but here's the way that I'm gonna I'm
gonna approach it with um Gauss's way of
thinking if what you did was you added
this sum to itself but backwards if you
added this sum to itself but you added
it in reverse order if you have a
hundred over here then you're gonna have
99 and then you're gonna have 98 and
you're counting down so what are your
last three terms three two and one gas
saw that this was handy because what he
had created was something which is very
very orderly notice the way I've written
it we usually write our equations all
the way across one line but I've written
it on two lines for a purpose do you see
that what I've created is a bunch of
pairs do you see that every term in the
in the first partial sum has a
counterpart in the second partial sum it
is the same series after all okay
because they've gone in reverse order
have a look what happens if you add up
this pair what do you get 101 right what
about this pair
101 now that's not a coincidence it's
not a coincidence it's because as your
from left to right you add one and as
you go from right to left you subtract
one so that's why you're getting the
same thing every single time does that
make sense so when you match them all up
and no matter how many terms there were
in the original series like you'd said
add up the first thousand numbers not
the first 100 numbers there would still
always be a counterpart there's always
going to be a matching right now what
I've found here is a whole bunch of 101
so what do I have on the left-hand side
I've got to lots of this partial sum
correct - lots of they're some of the
first I have your terms okay now because
we have written it in this way that s of
n is the sum of the first n terms we
know that there are humor me
how many terms in this fast result there
are n of them right so how many lots of
101 do you have here
100 of them that's what multiplication
is after all it's just repeated addition
okay so if what you want is actually not
double the sum but just the sum itself
then all you have to do to both sides is
divide by 2
that'll become 50 times 101 which gives
you the answer that gas trotted back
with in 15 seconds clever guy okay